[Musique]
libye en guise d'adieu à leur vieille
planète plate faisait des feux
d'artifice et lançait des confettis mais
les confettis tête aussitôt aspiré par
la pompe shadoks le deux pompiers qui
paraît qui prêtait sa porte du cosmo gun
crier victoire victoire le cosmo girls
est arrivé et les shadoks sans précèdent
entassés des confettis dans leur fusée
comme le précieux combustible atomique
l'egypte y trouver ça très amusant de
voir le confetti aspirer ils ont relancé
et ils ont relancé et plus les jb
s'amusait plus les shadoks pompey et
plus les confettis n'arrêtait pas
d'arriver
les libéraux profitèrent pour faire un
grand nettoyage de leur planète et se
débarrasser de toutes sortes d'ordures
gênante tels que papiers gras pot de
yaourt peau de banane et quantité
d'autres détritus
[Musique]
les shadoks prenait tout ça pour un
précieux combustible atomique et on
entassait le plus possible dans le
refuser
[Musique]